well handbag rentals it is a growing
trend right here in las vegas and all
over the country instead of spending
thousands on a designer purse or bag you
join a monthly subscription or trade one
in to save a few bucks sasha loftus has
a closer look at whether it's all worth
it
i just think it's fun jennifer inauda
loves the luxury of designer backs it's
really nice to have that flexibility
without the commitment at first glance
you'd think she owns a lot of them
but jennifer has a pretty cool secret
these high-end accessories are rented
people think why would i spend
a hundred dollars to rent something if i
can spend a thousand dollars to buy it
well you're still saving 900 dollars
she's one of many who's jumped on the
fashion trend using sites like rent the
runway or bag borrow or steal you pay a
small fee to get your hands on high-end
brands like louis vuitton or chanel
use them for a bit and send them back
you have to think of that bigger picture
of how many uses am i actually going to
get out of this do i really need it just
for a one time special occasion and is
it then just going to sit in my closet
and collect dust and rentals aren't the
only option for anyone wanting to look
great on the cheap we have demand from
tourists for events and weddings michael
mack of max pond says resale bags are a
big part of his game gorgeous bag right
here's how it works you buy a slightly
less expensive brand like coach or kate
spade keep it for a few months then
trade it in for a higher cost option and
work your way up from there we have a
lot of nurses and doctors and
professionals that love leyway and
remember layaway mack offers that too
say you have your eye on a 4200 dollar
purse
just put down 10 percent of that then
pay it off in 10 payments especially
with what's happening in the economy
today gas prices i mean people are
spending an extra sixty dollars a week
matt calls these options solid for
anyone who needs to save some cash right
now we have a lot of waste we have a lot
of over consumption and so that's a big
part of it for me while anaba also
believes this kind of reusing and
recycling is better for the environment
it's like having
like an online best friend's closet that
you can constantly go to and pick out
things so if you're on the fence about
taking the plunge
she says now could be the time
to try a bag like this on for size give
it a try i mean you really don't have
much to lose sasha loftis
live local now